The longer you run a cloud code session,
the number it gets,
and using Compact is not enough to fix it.
Compacting still drags the old conversation forward,
meaning it brings the dead ends,
the messy debugging,
and all the bad assumptions in the next conversation.
I call this context rot,
and it's killing your code.
So what you want instead is a full handoff.
So before you end a session,
tell Cloud to create a handoff.md file,
and have it include six things.
The goal, the current state,
active files that's working on,
any changes it made,
a list of failed attempts and specific next steps
that it was focused on.
Then run the forward slash clear command
or open a new session,
and tell it to read the handoff doc
and continue from where it left off.
And you want to use this
when you're stepping away for hours,
or when Cloud keeps making the same broken mistake on a loop.
Now I made a short guide that tells you exactly how to do
this and how to get started.
Comment clear below,
and I'll send it right over.